hello idiot army I'd like to welcome you
all to the reject nation since I know
all that you guys are over here Tara
Ericsson she has a YouTube channel
please follow it because it'll be worth
her time and it might solidify her
coming back on the channel this is true
hashtag this idiot stranger things comes
out in just a few weeks people and they
have these two teaser trailers here why
make two separate videos when you could
put it in one why would we try to get
more views that way let's just watch
them all in one and get less views you
guys like my yelling commentary me too
nosebleed is the first one
[Music]
[Music]
what do you think 450 means 450 means
there's gonna be 450 people that she
finds on the underneath and two of those
are the women that we just saw in that
teaser
there's noses bleed too one of them is
her mom she didn't know really
stretching here I think 450 is just the
time in which all this took place p.m.
you mean yeah it's a significant time
yeah I mean four is double the number of
250 is double the number of 25 and if
you divide those numbers by 2 you get
225 and 225 was the time of the birth of
one of the main characters the sheriff
yeah and the sheriff if you divide his
age by two equals 26 with that in mind
you get nothing this is why you come to
this channel to get proper stranger
things theories and predictions it's not
a waste of time sure isn't let's do this
1 2 3
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa who's that guy on Friday
the 13th watch the final trailer what's
[Music]
Oh as number 11 that girl haven't seen
her before also the boys in that weird
tunnel they looked grown and I don't
want them to grow up I want the same
boys from Caesar maybe they happen to
the future in some way oh maybe they do
hey that was great
that was like a great 80s horror trailer
that was fantastically done I even like
the filter they have to have that kind
of grainy eighties movie look because it
did make you feel really creepy I got
nipple chills from that that's really
hard haven't had those in a while well
you should get some yeah it changes our
life terror area said it does I wonder
if this one's gonna be scarier than last
season no it's coming out like a few
days before Halloween right and it takes
place around Halloween from my
understanding like they're dressed a lot
of these characters in with their jobs
when they get to number four you see oh
it's Steve Steve and they're not grown I
thought Steve was one of the boys that's
what you were juice back Steve no we
still got the great kids and we got
douche Aramis Steve that kid man you
catch him in the party at a party in the
first in the second season the trailer
and they're drinking Bud Light and I'm
like you can't get Nancy like something
different cuz I tell you who would get
her something different Jonathan he give
her a glass of wine he'd give her vibe
late
I forgot how it ended is she still with
Steve totally right she no wait wait
wait no they broke up but in the in the
trailer for season two the first trailer
was dropped
you see her at a party with Steve and
they're drinking so I think they got
back together damn it no way she did get
back with Steve because it's right
didn't he say he's like let me clean the
sign and you guys are jerks and then he
goes back to her and he apologizes but
when pologize kill the monster together
her Jonathan and Steve go hunting for
the monster together and then they all
get close I may have to just watch
season one again really fast I laid it
out for you okay I've got to take your
word for it well I liked seeing Steve
involved with actually working with the
kids instead of being being a jerk just
being mr. douche with this sheriff Chad
are we gonna shower down is he getting
experimented on in this season I don't
know but I see that a little bit of
blood I believe
chling down okay you've got to do a good
good positive
I really radioactive or he killed a
monster lice the monster in the monster
projectile blood
Wynonna is digging some [ __ ] she's
digging oh is she like digging up or
grave or is she killing someone but the
guy behind her doesn't look grossed out
but she's searching for something he
looks fine no no no no looks very
disturbed about it which i think is how
night life normally goes for her is that
people around her gone this is cool and
she's going like that is well that's not
the actual Winona Ryder we're talking
about yeah she'd realize that's care
who's the guy screaming with the dough
saying he looks very 80s it's Harris
dude he's got that curly mullet going on
with you I'm cool with it
who's the girl that's what I'm saying
who is that who's the person with the
lobotomy that was really creepy with the
clock coming up that was a cool effect
that was really creepy I'll use this
filter all any of the episodes it's like
grainy look trailer tomorrow oh man well
this video is going up at like 10:00
p.m. tonight
I'm probably gonna be a little late to
this trailer but you should do a
reaction on your channel I will you know
what you should do reaction on your
channel on tomorrow hey guys I'm gonna
do a reaction to the front to this
trailer the Friday the 13th trailer
stranger things - Friday 13th Gregory I
haven't written coffee today
yes check it out I'm gonna do reaction
tomorrow to this if I have time what
killing my life there's no time is it
gonna prop out in the morning probably
have a character class and then I have
to shoot something with my friend okay
and I have an audition I have a busy
life you can just sit around making
YouTube videos for my idiot army even
though that's only the thing that I want
to do forever and always
hey hey I had to yell and get really
serious because I just wanted them to
know how serious I yell it creates
defensive mechanisms to appear so please
Tara calm yourself got it converse he
got scared gosh that was my whole point
well this video has not gotten awkward
at all
hey can you subscribe to the real
rejects can you click that notification
Bell can you subscribe to the Tara
Ericsson channel keep a lookout for a
trailer reaction if it's not up tomorrow
it should be up over the weekend yeah
for sure click oh well I watch it watch
it
cuz he told you to and also you can
check out gregory alba a little clip of
him on my channel when the jollibee
thing that is dropped with amy castle
we're just a big group of friends he's
blinking weirdly I think maybe